[Aplausos]
o essencial é invisível aos olhos disse
santer sexo pr em 1943
engraçado a gente pensar invisível que
vem a nossa mente quando a gente pensa
invisível
talvez o filme a mulher invisível aquela
mulher ideal que só existe na cabeça do
ator selton mello
ou então na capa de invisibilidade do
harry potter tão desejada por crianças e
adolescentes naquela fase que a gente
quer assumir que a gente quer ser
invisível
a gente quer estudar a gente quer para
escola mas a invisibilidade ela não é
assim desejada por algumas pessoas e eu
vou contar pra vocês uma história de uma
jovem negra
moradora da periferia da zona sul da
cidade de são paulo que com 16 anos ela
sonhava em ser médica
ela não sabe ao certo de onde vem essa
vontade de ser médica
talvez a inspiração dela fosse avó preta
que contava histórias sobre escravidão
uma certeza aquela jovem tinha ela
queria atender pessoas
ela queria oferecer diagnósticos de cura
ela queria ser precisa ela queria ser
médica
e aí com o passar dos anos quando chegou
à fase do vestibular
ela foi contar a decisão para os pais
feliz e empolgada pai decidir vou fazer
medicina e o pai falou assim filha
medicina medicina não é pra gente não
existem médicos como agente que aquela
jovem ficou bem intrigada com que o pai
falou começou a observar nos hospitais
nos postos de saúde os ambulatórios
médicos e de fato no final dos anos 90
aqui no brasil a maioria dos médicos era
de homens
brancos de classe média alta e de
família já médica bom aquela jovem
desistiu da medicina começou a pensar em
outras opções de carreira foi para a
faculdade de educação física ficou dois
anos desistiu por causa de uma lesão no
joelho foi para a faculdade de pedagogia
pensou na educação
vou realizar um pedacinho do meu sonho
pelo menos atender pessoas e após uma
experiência frustrada na educação
infantil
ela conseguiu um estágio em uma grande
emissora de televisão e o que ela fez
foi para casa feliz contar para os pais
pai conseguir um estágio na televisão
vou trabalhar na televisão e o pai filha
televisão televisão não é pra gente na
tv não existem
gente como a gente e ela retrucou mas
parry
eu vou trabalhar nos bastidores eu vou
trabalhar no administrativo
eu não vou trabalhar na frente das
câmeras e ele falou filha mesmo assim
não existem
gente como a gente e gente negra como a
gente
engraçado que aquela jovem já com 20
anos começou a perceber que o pai tinha
razão nem nas frentes das câmeras e o
pior ela percebeu a que o pai tinha
razão
durante o trabalho dela de seleção de
profissionais não vinham nem candidatos
negros nem para os cargos
administrativos nem para os cargos
operacionais para os cargos estratégicos
não vinham candidatos negras não tinham
candidatos negros não tinham negros na
frente das câmeras eram invisíveis
já faz 20 anos que aquela jovem ganhou
com a medicina
aquela jovem sou eu
[Aplausos]
hoje eu pratico uma medicina diferente
eu faço o diagnóstico da doença do
invisível eu freqüentemente entram nos
lugares e falo para as empresas a
importância de olhar para o talento
olhar para o profissional negro que não
aparece que parece que não existe
eu falo que as possibilidades de
tratamento comigo são inúmeras
pode se ser doses homeopáticas a pode
ser dov na veia
desde palestras cursos treinamentos
workshops coaching de carreira
desenvolvimento profissional existe cura
para a cegueira eu ofereço a cura para a
doença mais difícil é aquela que não se
vê e com o tempo eu percebi que o meu
pai um homem nordestino negro que fugiu
de casa aos 18 anos para tentar uma vida
na capital
na verdade ele queria me proteger do
preconceito e da discriminação
ele queria que eu não passasse por
tantas situações que ele passou e eu de
fato só pude perceber quando eu estava
na minha primeira oportunidade de
trabalho na área de rh há 16 anos e com
as histórias que a mesma contava com
essa proteção do meu pai de certa forma
com a força da minha mãe porque minha
mãe sempre disse você pode ser o que
você quiser e hoje com o estímulo do meu
marido ea responsabilidade que eu sei
que eu tenho de deixar um legado para os
meus quatro filhos
eu sei que eu sou a ponte pra muito
jovem negro da periferia que quer
trabalhar em grandes multinacionais
eu sou a esperança profissionais negros
que sonham em trabalhar em grandes
empresas
eu sei que eu sou até a esperança para
executivos que querem ascender
profissionalmente que querem ter uma
oportunidade de ocupar ainda mais cargos
executivos e eu espero sinceramente que
todos vocês que estão aqui hoje
espero sinceramente que todos sejam
incomodados com o invisível
vamos todos os incomodados com a falta
de jovens negros nas universidades sejam
incomodados com a falta de jovens negros
nos processos seletivos sejamos
incomodados com a falta de profissionais
nas propagandas sejam incomodados com a
falta de negros
sejamos todos incomodados
parafraseando santex super ri
a diversidade é essencial à vida
corporativa deve ser visível aos olhos
obrigada
o pai